There once lived a poor woodcutter, his wife and two children Hansel and Gretel.
The woodcutter and his wife could not take care of the children anymore.
They decided to leave them in the middle of the forest.
Hansel and Gretel heard this and were very scared.
They came up with a plan of dropping pebbles along the way their father took them.
All they had to do was follow the line of pebbles back home.
Their parents were surprised to see them and decided to take them again.
Hansel and Gretel decided to drop bread crumbs this time as their pebbles were gone.
But sadly for the children, the animals and birds ate up all the crumbs.
They walked and walked but couldn't find their way back home.
Suddenly, they saw a strange house made up of cookies, candies and chocolates.
Just as Hansel and Gretel were eating the yummy door, a witch pounced on them.
She locked up Hansel in a cage and asked Gretel to help her heat the oven.
She would cook them and eat them up.
But just as the witch bent to check the oven's temperature,...
...Gretel pushed her from behind and locked the oven door.
Gretel rescued Hansel, and they filled their pockets with the witch's jewels.
Finally, they managed to find their way back home...
...and gave the jewels to their parents.
Thanks to the clever children, the family was never poor and hungry again.